[MUSIC PLAYING]
JD VALASQUEZ: Welcome all.
Thank you for joining us today.
Kind of like this environment--
a little more intimate,
and feels very
Google-y, in a sense.
And so, my name is JD.
I'm a product manager
with Stackdriver.
And I'm here today with
Shoucong Chen, who's
going to join us later,
who's technical lead
for our Kubernetes
monitoring experience.
Hence, we're going to
tell you a little bit
today about how do we do
Kubernetes monitoring,
a little bit in the
way that Google does.
Some of you-- let
me just check here--
who was, yesterday, in the
talk, the hybrid monitoring
and logging session?
A few people, OK.
So you'll see it--
very much the same
demo, in a sense
and a few more other
things that we're
going to show you as well.
So let's get started.
We have that introduction,
where, as I said,
we're going to try to go
through a couple of scenarios,
how we monitor and troubleshoot
Kubernetes in production.
We'll talk about some
of the best practices
that we do, and a little
bit about oberservability,
and so forth.
We do assume some basic
knowledge on Kubernetes,
of course, as we're doing
some things here in that end.
So first thing is let's
talk about observability,
reliability, and
software velocity.
Just a quick show of hands--
who here is a developer?
All right, almost everybody.
Anybody in operations?
A few as well.
And who does,
like, truly DevOps.
OK.
So great.
So let's-- thank you, everyone.
All of you developers
and many of you
who may be our partners,
our customers, and so on--
you know that software velocity
now becomes a real necessity.
It's a competitive advantage.
For you to be able to
innovate in your market,
to compete for business,
compete for some customers,
and so on, you really want
to be able to accelerate
the pace of your software
velocity and the innovation,
and so on.
Now the difficult
thing, however,
is to do that, while
at the same time,
maintaining reliability, right?
You're able to do one
or the other very well.
Now, one of the key things
that Google has done,
that it's very good at, is for
almost two decades now, we've
been able to have a
great pace of innovation,
while still maintaining
software reliability,
and also minimizing
security exposure.
So there's something that Google
has done, at massive scale,
of being able to do
both of these things.
And so what we're
trying to do now--
on our team and on the
SRE group and so on--
is to externalize many of
these SRE practices, so
that our customers and
our developers and so on
can do the same things in
the way that Google does.
Now, when I say monitoring
or developing the way
that Google does,
sometimes I get, you know,
high eyebrows saying, well,
we don't have the scale
that Google does.
And we don't need to do
exactly the same things.
Now, our point is that,
yes, regardless of scale,
you do want to take advantage
of some of these best practices,
because you do face the
same type of issues.
The way you want to
deploy applications,
the way you want
to monitor them,
and so on are the same type
of problems, just the scale
might be different.
So let's talk a little
bit about that in general.
Kubernetes is an example of how
we've been doing this, right?
The way that Google
does things today--
everything pretty much
runs in a container, like,
all-- we have an
internal system.
We call it Borg.
Well, everything is isolated
very much in a container cell.
So, as you see here,
we really were,
you know, on average on a
week, we launch more than 4
billion containers.
So we've certainly
amassed some experience
in how to deploy and
then manage these type
of container-based applications.
And so what we're trying to
do now with our processes
and our tools is to externalize
those best practices precisely.
And we've been doing
this in multiple ways.
The first one is
our infrastructure.
So internally, aside
from of course,
our [INAUDIBLE] infrastructure
we call Google Three,
it's done in a way,
where developers,
from the very beginning,
they can really
focus on writing code.
A lot of the instrumentation
is ready-- happens
sort of automatically.
We know the type of things
that that infrastructure
is expecting.
So we can do some things
automatically, right?
Now, of course, we cannot
just put Google Three out.
But we've done some
of these things
via some of the
externalizations,
like Kubernetes, precisely.
Right?
Kubernetes is, in some
ways, like externalization
of our Borg infrastructure
and practices.
Now, you saw yesterday
on the keynote
our Google Cloud Service
platform announcement
with Istio and so on.
So we've done a similar thing
to manage services across
in coordination.
So Istio is an example.
For instrumentation, we use
something called Census.
And Google has invested
now in externalizing
that via OpenCensus.
So the intent here
is to give you
a way in which you can
instrument your application one
way, one time.
And then you can choose multiple
backends, and switch over.
You may want to use Google's
Stackdriver as a backend.
Or you may want to use
a different backend
to do your monitoring
and your operations.
And that's fine,
because you don't
need to go back and change
your instrumentation.
And that's the way
we do it internally,
and that's what we're
doing now outside.
And the same thing, in terms
of our procedure calls,
we now have GRPC as
an externalization.
So that's the infrastructure
and people in some sense, right?
The process that we do.
Now best practices--
we, you know,
I"m using the collective "we."
I had nothing to
do with that book.
But we at Google SRE, well, we
wrote the book on operations,
literally.
Site reliability engineering--
and who here has visited
the Fifth Nine on Moscone West?
If you haven't-- just
a couple of hands--
stop by.
It's a booth with
all of our SRE team.
And you get ideas.
You can actually get a free
copy of the book and sign up
and everything else.
I invite you to do that.
So we've amassed
all these practices.
We're now externalizing
it, in terms
of books, white papers,
training, and certifications,
and so on.
When I look at LinkedIn
just very recently,
on my profile, at least, I saw
roughly about 26,000 people
with roles now that
have SRE in the title.
So we're certainly now making
[? a ?] [? mess ?] in terms
of changing a little bit of the
culture involved in this type
of practices.
And then finally it's
our tools, of course.
If we don't have
the right tools that
are trying to implement the
same type of workflows that
comes from those best
practices and those processes,
then you have a mismatch.
And so now Stackdriver is
an example of that tool.
It started initially
as an acquisition we
did 4 and 1/2 years ago or so.
But that was just the beginning.
That was focusing on
just a small piece of it,
which was monitoring.
And we've expanded that into
a full product suite that
now has multiple components.
So let me tell you a little
bit about the Stackdriver now.
It's a fully managed
product we have on cloud.
And the main mission
that we have on our team
is to help developers
and operators keep
your applications running
fast and always available.
And a key thing here
with Stackdriver
is that it was built
from the ground up
to help you do your apps
and monitor your apps,
no matter where they run.
They may be running
on Google Cloud.
They may be running on AWS.
They may be running on
cloud-native infrastructure
as we'll show today
with Kubernetes.
And now with the
Kubernetes monitoring,
then we also have
the possibility
to monitor on prem as well.
Now, all of this is built
on a massive platform
that we have at Google in
our backends and our stores
and so on.
And the key thing here
is that what we're doing
is we're amassing
a lot of signals
throughout the full stack,
starting from our cloud
services, from Google Cloud,
from AWS, to operating
system and third-party
application components.
Let's say, in your
app, you're using--
let's say, Nginx, Radix, Kafka--
anything that's out there
as a third-party application
component, all the way
to your main application
in your business,
what it's meant
to do-- so all those signals.
We get all of those together.
It's not just about monitoring.
It's not just about metrics.
It's actually logs, metrics,
events, snapshots from debugs,
traces.
And we get all those signals
together into our backends.
Our backends [? have ?] stores.
And we have, though-- this
is the-- this part that I
mentioned was a
massive platform.
To give you an
idea, we monitor--
in this time series database
that we have internally,
we monitor more than
3 billion resources,
roughly about 480
terabytes of RAM,
because it's a highly
distributed in-memory time
series database.
On our logging backend,
we have in a day,
roughly 35 petabytes of data.
So it's a massive infrastructure
that we have, and now are
putting outside for all
of you to use and take
advantage of that.
Stackdriver is built on
top of that infrastructure.
And so what we do is
we use that and then
we create a set of tools
that we have exposed
to all of our customers.
So we can do visualizations,
use them in dashboards,
create multi-conditioning
alerts,
have notification channels
to many different ways.
And to do that, we actually
rely on many of our partners.
So what we're doing is we
actually are building all this,
because we know we cannot be
everything to everybody, right?
There's things
that we cannot do.
It's not our core focus.
And so many of our partners
come in and fill that gap.
But most importantly,
many of those
partners come in and fill--
can help us build that ecosystem
and create it much better,
build value on top
of this platform.
So we have a few of our
partners here today.
Many of you-- you'll see here.
Now, I'm actually got
excited to talk specifically
about one partner, xMatters.
We just announced a
partnership with them.
And they're helping us build
a set of notification channels
and integrations so
that it helps customers
when they're using Stackdriver.
If you get a notification when
there's a particular incident--
there was a failure--
now using xMatters,
our customers
will have the ability
to then integrate
with many other
services, including
dozens and perhaps hundreds
of integrations in that sense.
So it really helps customers
get to the core of an issue
and resolve things
faster and so forth.
So let's go now, briefly, into
our monitoring offering today--
the Kubernetes
monitoring solution.
And you know that
building modern apps,
it's quite different from what
it used to be in the past.
Today many of you
raised your hands,
saying you're a developer.
And I wish most of you want to
just focus on building code.
Am I right?
Yes.
If you could.
We can't anymore, right?
There's so many things
that we have to do.
We want to choose
our infrastructure.
We want to do setups.
Then we're going to
do containerization,
work with a specific
orchestration system,
most likely Kubernetes,
choose storage, instrument
our applications to do--
then monitoring, set up our
monitoring and observability
tools, and so on.
So getting observability--
and, by the way,
I'm using the term
"observability" here.
And I know it sort of became
kind of like a buzz word
recently.
But at Google, we truly mean--
and from many years ago.
We've been talking more
about observability.
It's not just monitoring.
Monitoring is one
piece of things.
Monitoring is just that
activity of going in and looking
at specific things
to prevent failure.
Observability is more
a property of a system.
So from the beginning,
what we're trying to do
is to get our systems
being designed
with reliability in mind.
It really is an
engineering practice.
And so we're trying to
increase the signals.
That's why you see metrics,
logs, traces all together,
because we're trying to
increase the observability
of our systems so we can
know how they are operating
under normal circumstances
and also how they
operate when there's failure.
So that way we can quickly
resolve issues, speed-read cost
analysis, and help us resolve
the issue and then [INAUDIBLE]..
Kubernetes actually makes
things a little bit trickier,
because, on the one hand, it
gives us so much flexibility.
It's great.
We start with new
microservices, so it really
allows us to break this monolith
into multiple micro services.
But that means that we have more
pieces to monitor and operate.
The second thing is
that we, of course,
have abstracted infrastructure.
We have so much flexibility.
You can use different types
of controllers and deployments
and StatefulSets and all
these different components.
And then, again, when
you're using those,
now you have to infer the
state of those components
when something goes wrong.
So you really want to be able
to have pretty well-spread-out
observability throughout your
entire Kubernetes environment.
And finally,
Kubernetes is really
a highly dynamic environment.
If you're using auto-scaling
and, of course, the scheduling
and restarting and so on,
that's a natural occurrence
in Kubernetes.
So you want to be able
to have a system that
allows you to always know the
state of where things are,
no matter where they are.
And, of course,
you're not really
looking at your
applications necessarily,
like, knowing which
machine they are, right?
That's the idea.
We want you to not think
about any of those things.
And so-- but that
means now that you
need to keep track of
where your application is
and what it's doing and so on.
So what we have right
now is a new solution,
which is Stackdriver
Kubernetes Monitoring
that we announced recently.
It's in beta.
And we've been
expanding it rapidly.
So we invite you-- all of
you-- to please start using it,
if you haven't already.
Give us feedback.
The feedback that you
give us right now,
we directly are
reading those messages.
So we want to build a product
that is most useful to you.
There's many things that
are not available yet
in Stackdriver
Kubernetes Monitoring.
We want to get those things
out to you as fast as possible.
So let me go through it, very
rapidly, some of the things
that we have.
First, it's comprehensive
observability.
What do I mean by that?
Out of the box, without
you having to do anything,
you get all this instrumentation
done for free, so to speak.
You get instrumentation on
all your Kubernetes objects.
And you get not just metrics.
You get metrics, logs, and
we have traces as well.
And there's events and
metadata and so on-- so really
trying to increase that.
It works very well
with open source.
From the ground up, we
built it and integrated it
with Prometheus,
which is, of course,
the most well-known
monitoring open source
solution for Kubernetes.
It's multi-cluster
monitoring, which
is a difference that you
see from many other products
outside.
In a single place,
we're giving you
a way to do multiple monitoring
of multiple clusters.
And it doesn't
matter where it runs.
We can monitor your cluster
on-prem or your cluster
on Kubernetes engine or your
cluster running on AWS EC2
instances, for instance.
One last thing that I
would say in this respect
is the fact that if you have
the observability no matter what
your role is.
So it goes back to that idea of
this platform that we created.
This platform for us created
a single source of truth.
Many of you are using
multiple tools, very likely.
And what we do is we have just
that single platform where all
these signals come together.
So you don't have to stitch and
cobble together multiple tools
to try to create
that source of truth.
So if you're a
DevOps or an SRE, you
may want to look primarily
at your infrastructure.
If you're a developer,
you may look
at your application
and your workloads
and so on, which we'll
show in the demo.
And if you're a
security engineer,
you may actually be looking
at your logs and audit logs
and audit trail and so on.
That's actually also
part of Stackdriver.
So I mentioned before it works
very well with open source,
with Prometheus.
One of the main maintainers of
Prometheus, Fabian Reinartz,
joined Google--
our team-- just a
couple of months ago.
So we're directly
working with him
to make sure that we continue
to contribute to Prometheus,
to expand and contribute
to this vibrant community,
and ultimately to make it very
easy to switch and make sure
that Prometheus integrations
can move into cloud when it's
appropriate and when
wanted and needed.
So this is what we'll
be seeing today--
a hybrid, multi-cluster approach
for Kubernetes Monitoring.
And I think the best way to
do that is through our demo.
But one last thing I'll
say is that this offering
works very well self-contained.
You get your Kubernetes
observability.
But it works even
better when you use it
with the rest of the
Stackdriver tools.
And hopefully at the end we'll
show you a little bit of this.
The idea, again, by using
all these tools and signals
together is that we try to give
you a means to speed your root
cause analysis.
You'll see in a
couple of the demos
here that we're trying
to focus your attention
into the information that
matters the most to you so
that you follow the
trail that we believe
is the one most likely to give
you the root cause for things.
So with that, I'll
turn to Shoucong,
who is going to
tell us a little bit
about the internal architecture.
SHOUCONG CHEN: OK.
Thanks, JD.
So this is Shoucong.
I'm the tech lead of a sector
of Kubernetes Monitoring.
Can we switch back to
slides for one second, and--
switch back to slides, please.
Oh, can we switch back
to slides for one second?
Yeah?
So I'm going to give you a
very brief overview about what
our Stackdriver Kubernetes
monitoring architecture is.
So as you can see, so
there's a [? Kubernete ?]
running in your cluster.
So there we have some of
the Kubernetes metrics--
very important one,
like the CPU usage,
restart [INAUDIBLE]
and whatever is there
are collecting by the Heapster.
And we offer a sector--
we have a monitoring API, which
is public on the internet.
So Heapster is sending this
metric into our monitoring API,
and that is how we
collect system metric
for your Kubernetes application.
At the same time,
we have the sector
of Prometheus collector,
which is a [INAUDIBLE] running
in your port.
And it collects-- scrape all
the Prometheus metrics that's
available there for
your config, and also
right into our monitoring API.
So this is the
[? path ?] for how
metrics fall into Stackdriver.
In the same time, we
have the two daemon sets.
One is the Stackdriver
metadata agent.
It collects all the matter that
are likely in Kubernetes label,
your hierarchy in
your Kubernetes,
and what all the
configure is specified,
and then sending it to the
resource matter to the API.
And the logging agent is
also another daemon set.
It collects all your standard
outs, standard error, all
your--
other logs you care about--
and then sending it to our
logging API, which is backend
is our logging storage.
This is the architecture
of these offerings.
So we want to explore
a little bit more
about how Prometheus metrics
integrates-- happens.
So as you can see here,
so that on the top is--
the gray chart-- is like how
you do Prometheus metrics
in open source.
So there's official
Prometheus collector,
scraping the Prometheus parts
and then sending that data
and graphing in Grafana.
On Stackdriver, we
have another way--
another Prometheus collector,
which it collects data
and then sending
it to Stackdriver
backend, which is
Cloud Monarch, which
is our Google planet-scale
time series database,
which JD has mentioned before.
It supports all of
our Google workload,
including all of
Google Cloud Platform.
Now, it's a time series
database for that.
And we have the
Stackdriver monitoring UI,
which is graph the times
series data from Monarch.
You can also use our Grafana
integration-- use Grafana
to read from the
Monarch to graph
whatever dashboard you want.
So this is the
brief introduction
about our architecture.
Now, let's go to the demo time.
One more slide.
I will explain-- so this
is a very [INAUDIBLE]
demo that probably some
of you have already seen.
It's a PetClinic from
a screen communication.
And so, how many
of you have pets?
Like, if you raise the hand--
oh, come on you have--
oh, OK, we have plenty
of people that have pets.
So as you can see,
today we are going
to use this PetClinic demo to--
this is going to give
you a list of owners
and then some of the pet
with it, pet information,
and then assign the
doctor for your pet.
So let me very briefly describe
how this application is set up.
So as you can see,
we say this is
today's demo is a hybrid demo.
So that's why we
still have a GKE
cluster and an on-prem cluster.
They are both
running the same app.
As you can see,
that's an API gateway.
It was just routing
all your traffic
into different backends.
That's our customer
service, which
give you the detail of
owners, and the visit service,
which tell you what's your
visit to the PetClinic
and assign doctor service,
all of this connecting
to a remote cloud spanner
storage with all of your data.
So this is the setup.
OK.
So I'm handing back to JD.
And-- but we will run a demo
for this proactive monitoring.
Can we switch to demo?
JD VALASQUEZ: [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks, Shoucong.
All right, so let's
try to show you
a little bit of this application
so we get a sense for it
and orient ourselves.
So as Shoucong was saying, it's
just an app, very simple one.
Allows you to get
information for-- as an owner
of a veterinary
clinic, I just track
who are my customers,
what pets they have,
what visits they've done to the
veterinary clinic, and so on.
So let's show the list of
owners, Shoucong, right now.
Get a sense for those.
The app, you may see it.
It's a little bit
flaky on purpose,
to try to show some issues
with latency and other things.
So what we're going to
do here is add a new pet
to a pet owner.
And we can do, I
guess, the same one,
add the date of birth,
and then the type.
Maybe you want introduce
[? a bug ?] with the cat,
just in case we want to use
it later, maybe if we do
add another pet.
And-- that's a
very apropos name.
So we introduced a little thing
here, so we get error requests
and so forth, just in
case they may be useful
for us to demonstrate
other things later
on, if we have time.
All right.
And now we can do other things.
We can add visits
for the pets, if we
want to have more data and
traffic into this application.
But what we're going to do
now is to actually create
some actual traffic for it.
We would be asking you,
as we did in the demo
yesterday, asking you to
do this, in particular,
but let's do it now today.
We have one command.
What Shoucong is
doing right now is
we're going to our
on-prem cluster.
And now we're adding--
we're actually
scaling that cluster
to make sure it
simulates some traffic.
Let's do the same
now on the GKE side.
We run the same exact command.
We're just going to scale
up our low generator
and then essentially creating
that particular traffic here
for Kubernetes.
Now, as Shoucong
mentioned, you have
many ways of doing monitoring.
You could have done Prometheus
and Grafana, most likely
if you're using open source.
What we're going
to do today is just
focus on the Kubernetes
monitoring experience.
So we're going to do just that.
Why don't we try to go now into
Kubernetes Monitoring, which
we do by going into
our cloud console.
We choose the monitoring piece
from the Stackdriver section.
That gets you into the
Stackdriver console.
This is the Stackdriver
Monitoring piece.
Remember, Stackdriver
is actually
a full-- a suite
with many components
right now-- six
different components.
So we're in the
monitoring console now.
And by going through
resources and Kubernetes,
we'll get to the Kubernetes
Monitoring offer.
And so you see here essentially
that Kubernetes Monitoring
console right now.
And just let me try to
orient ourselves here
a little bit on this console.
On the upper side,
you see that widget--
it's the event timeline.
It's our event widget.
What we're trying to do here
is surface Kubernetes events
that may be relevant to you.
And this is actually a heat map.
So you see the more
transparent colors?
The more solid colors
actually have higher frequency
of events.
The less solid ones are
less events and so on.
Now you modify time
sets and other things.
But the important thing here is
that we want to surface events
that you can then correlate with
the state of your Kubernetes
environment.
Today, in beta,
we're just surfacing
events related to incidents.
Now, incidents are
essentially violations
of your alerting policies.
So you created alerting
policies by defining
[INAUDIBLE] conditions
that you believe
are your own notion
of health, right?
Something you would say
this is, when this happens,
most likely a failure or a
situation we want to avoid,
perhaps, is likely to occur.
So we want to use those.
When a failure occurs,
we create an incident.
And those are the ones
you're seeing here.
Now, let's focus our
attention on the pane below.
This is our
multi-cluster monitoring.
And as you can see here, there's
already two clusters-- the ones
that we have, out of the box.
You actually get those clusters
together in a single place.
Now for the GKE cluster, there's
nothing you need to do, right?
No action is needed.
You get pre-integration
with Kubernetes engine.
All the data gets in, and
there's nothing to do.
For the on-prem cluster, the
only thing you need to do
is deploy the Stackdriver
agents, so the agents
that Shoucong showed
us earlier, a metadata
agent, and the logging
agent, and so on.
We deploy those with a very
simple set of instructions.
Now, in this pane
down below, we also
try to [? surface ?]
information that is
key to give you a sense of
the health of your cluster.
So we have [? part ?] readiness.
We have incidents that may have
occurred in any of the objects.
And we have some key consumption
utilization for resources,
and so on, like CPU and memory
relative to requests and limits
that you may have
created on these objects.
The other thing that I want
to show you is the fact that--
I mentioned this before
in one of the slides--
no matter the role you have,
you can choose a different view
on this part.
So if you're an operator
or SRE, then you
may want to actually look
in your infrastructure
and take a look at your nodes
and the health of your nodes
and how performant
they are and so on.
So we can do that.
If you're a developer,
then you may actually
want to look at your
deployments or your services
of your application.
And so Shoucong showed
us a few more earlier.
And there we go.
We have one of our--
the default namespace
that he's going in.
And notice right away that
there's something here.
And this is what
I meant earlier.
Now because we scaled up-- and
Shoucong was going to show us
that in a minute--
something is going on.
You immediately see
that there's something
we're focusing your attention
on the pieces of Kubernetes
that you may want to
look at right now.
And Shoucong will demonstrate
that in a little bit
more detail in a minute.
So you can go now
into the details
of many of these
Kubernetes objects
simply by inspecting
them on demand.
So here we just
clicked on a pod,
and you can see that
it's still ready.
It's running.
It actually has an incident
open, that pod specifically,
so you know there's something
particular in that pod.
And then I can go in
detail through the rest
of the key metrics--
memory, storage,
networking, and so forth.
And in the same place, we also
includes logs and metadata
for you.
So now it's really logs that
are only relevant for that pod,
for that particular period
of time, events and metadata
that are only relevant for
that particular period of time
in those components.
And that's what I meant
earlier about trying
to increase the observability
of your Kubernetes environment,
not just having you to look for
those things in separate tools
all together, but
rather bringing
all those signals
in the same place
at the right time with
the right context.
Now, one last thing that
I wanted to show you
was that you can use
all the other features
that you have in Stackdriver.
But particularly, when you're
trying to resolve incidents,
very likely you want to
explore things on demand.
We mentioned before, we have
an integration with Prometheus.
So all this Prometheus metrics
have been already ingested
into Stackdriver.
So we're going to take a look
at those with the metrics
explorer.
And with metric
explorers, you have
access to all of the objects and
components of Kubernetes, all
the metrics that are available.
And as Shoucong is
showing us right now,
we have all the Prometheus
metrics ingested already.
So take a look at one of the
JVM metrics that we have.
This is a Java application,
so we have one of them.
We can do the memory used bytes,
have some interesting signals,
Shoucong, that we can show.
So we've got autocompletion
will get you to the metrics
that you need very fast.
And then use bytes.
So we have a lot of
signals in that sense.
It may be hard to figure
out exactly what's going on.
But what we can do is we
added a lot of dimensions
to these Kubernetes objects.
And so now you have
labels and metadata
that are coming from
your environment
or even from user-defined
labels that you
can use to filter and aggregate
and group by to get you right,
very fast, to where you need.
And so let's filter now by
service name as you're doing.
And we knew before there was
something with API Gateway
above.
So let's filter by that one.
And then you can further group
by something else or aggregate
to not just have
a sum but rather
perhaps a mean or
a 99th percentile
or something of the sort.
And then the last
thing that you can do
is you also do outlier mode.
So we still have a
lot of signals here.
So you can look at
the top end objects.
And so we're now looking
at the top three,
top five containers by
JVM memory used bytes.
So that gives you
just a whirlwind tour
of the main things that you
can do on the monitoring
piece with the integration of
metrics, logs, and so forth.
So I'm going to
switch with Shoucong
so we can look at more of the
troubleshooting scenario that's
started to occur right now.
SHOUCONG CHEN: OK.
So I'm going to give a demo
about a troubleshooting
scenario.
So as a software engineer
or operation engineer,
one of the very common
error case that will happen
and we'll deal
with in daily work
is when your
application is receiving
a large volume of traffic.
Your application may become
less responsive or slow.
And so this is what we have
simulated a moment ago,
if you'll recall.
While JD is speaking,
we generate traffic
to both Kubernetes engine
cluster and on-prem cluster.
And while you were
watching the previous demo,
[INAUDIBLE] as the
[? encore ?] engineer
has been paged by incident.
So let's go to my Gmail account.
And I see there already
are two incident reports
have been sent again to me.
For example, this
incident tells me there
are too many 500 has been
returned from my services.
And on the bottom of
this incident report,
there's a View
Incident link, which
will redirect me to the
Stackdriver incident overview
page.
So as you can see
here, so my service
is apparently returning
a lot of 500 response.
And this is concerning
because this is how
my customers are experiencing.
And this is too many 500s,
more than my SOO allows.
So I want to resolve this
issue as soon as possible.
Let's move to the
custom dashboard
I have previously built
for my hybrid environments.
So this is a custom
dashboard I built
before there to draw
several charts about very
useful metrics to help me
observe my hybrid environments.
Let's quickly go through them.
So on the first row, there are
two charts about my activity
request rate and error rate.
This is [? to ?]
[? slice ?] by the cluster.
And on the second row,
there are two JVM metrics
because my PetClinic app
is a Java application.
So JVM metrics that were
important for me and this
is corrected by Prometheus.
And it's installed
in Stackdriver.
I also have the CPU limit
utilization and memory limit
utilization and [INAUDIBLE].
Some are classical
system metrics.
I will take a look.
So this is a at-a-glance
view of this dashboard.
Let's see how we can use it.
So from the first
chart, we already
see there's a reasonable amount,
about 300 requests per second,
goes to both my on-prem cluster
and Kubernetes engine cluster.
This is working as
intended because this is
one my load balancer can fix.
But if we look at a second
chart, which is my error rates,
I can see that's about
all of the 500 rates
are coming from my
on-prem cluster.
So it's a permanent,
very strong signal
to tell me there's something
wrong in my on-prem cluster.
As a natural reaction,
I may want to dive
into my on-prem cluster and
figure out what's wrong there.
But our SI best practice tell
us we should [? compare ?]
and mitigate the issue first.
So the ideal solution here is
we drain the on-prem cluster
and failover its traffic
to somewhere else.
The first choice is our
Kubernetes engine closer.
But before I do that, I want to
ensure the additional safety.
I want make sure my Kubernetes
engine cluster can sustain
the load if I double the size.
So let's go to the
Kubernetes monitoring UI
and take a look at the
infrastructure view.
If we expand the
Kubernetes engine cluster,
we will see there
are six nodes there.
Some of the nodes
are reasonably busy.
But most of them are empty.
So it gives me confidence
I can failover the traffic
into this Kubernetes
engine cluster,
and it's more than enough
to sustain the load.
So let's go ahead and do it.
So from this terminal, what
JD is doing is to scale down,
manually drain the
on-prem cluster
by scaling the traffic down.
In the same time, we
will go to a Cloud
SQL for Kubernetes engine.
And that's [INAUDIBLE]
scale of the traffic.
So this is how we do the
manually failover from one
cluster to another cluster.
And then after the
command finish,
let's go back to
our custom dashboard
to see how the traffic goes.
As you can see here
from the charts,
our on-prem cluster
traffic has been dropping.
And our 500 is also dropping.
In a moment later--
I mean, about two
minutes later, we
will see the Kubernetes engine
cluster traffic going up.
So because we already
see the 500 is dropping,
this give us a
reasonable confidence
this issue has been contained
since every minute counts
in my firefighting scenario.
So let's just jump directly
into identifying the root cause.
And then we will go back and
see whether my app has been back
into a normal state
in two minutes.
Let's go to Kubernetes monitor
UI and go to a service tab
because it is where the
service is returning 500.
And open the on-prem cluster.
As you can see there,
the incident [INAUDIBLE]
column gives you a
very clear signal
where you should focus
your attention to.
This is like we need
to go through on-prem
and [INAUDIBLE] spaces.
And apparently API Gateway
is the problematic one.
Let's expand it and then
inspect the parsing side of it.
So let's click on [INAUDIBLE].
We see there's a container
returning too many 500s.
And from first chart
is a container restart.
It doesn't have any restarts.
It's a good signal.
That means my container
is running healthy.
And we see the memory
usage is reasonably high,
but it's not out of whack.
And we also see the CPU usage.
It's also, like, about 80% use.
Because we are receiving a lot
of traffic, it is reasonable.
Storage is flat.
Network usage is high
because we are receiving
high amount of traffic.
So after looking all
these system metrics,
it doesn't seem to tell me
my Kubernetes infrastructure
is having any issue.
Then what could be the issue?
At this moment, it's the
log that will help us a lot.
As you can see here,
there's a log [INAUDIBLE]
has been drawn here.
And you can see, there's
an unreasonable amount
of error logs has been written.
About 40% of your
log are errors.
And if we go down to
the logs [INAUDIBLE]
we can [INAUDIBLE]
see there's something
has been throwing here.
It'll probably go away because
we have drained the cluster.
Let's go to a logs viewer.
Go to login link on the bottom.
And that will redirect me to a
logs viewer with more focused
view to get more details.
This will filter down directly
into the spots [INAUDIBLE]
I was looking at.
And they're restricted
to the time frame
when my incident happened.
This matters the most for me.
As you can see here
from the logs viewer,
we already see dozens of
[INAUDIBLE] of the exception
have being thrown from my code.
As you can see, there's
a runtime exception
with the error message, unable
to fetch details for owner1.
And this tells me
something's wrong in my code.
And this is a stack trace.
So I can scroll
down further and see
where this problematic
[INAUDIBLE] has been thrown.
As you can see here, this is
the API Gateway controller,
line 54.
It's the one where the
error has been thrown.
Now it gives me a
very good confidence
that probably this can help
me understand something.
Let's go to code.
Apparently, it's
not in this file.
Let me do it.
JD VALASQUEZ: [INAUDIBLE]
SHOUCONG CHEN: Yep.
JD VALASQUEZ: You know
what we should do?
We should show the
debugger as well.
SHOUCONG CHEN: Yeah, sure.
OK.
So this is the file where
the API Gateway is there.
And then we remember
the error message.
We see it's unable to
fetch details for owner1.
So that's apparently three
very problematic lines there.
Somebody from my team
has inserted this line
to throw 500 after
tossing a coin.
This is like why my on-prem
cluster is returning 500
for a portion of my traffic.
So I've already
identified the root cause.
The next step for me
is to fix the back,
re-deploy the app to my on-prem
cluster, and drain my cluster.
Then it will bring all my hybrid
environment back to normal.
So as you can see
from this demo,
Stackdriver
Kubernetes monitoring
integrates all the metrics,
logs, metadata [INAUDIBLE]
that can give you
the observability you
need to monitor and troubleshoot
your hybrid environments.
We also want to give you
one more demo about one
other very fancy thing here.
So as you'll see,
the scenario as shown
is a very simple
troubleshooting because looking
at the three lines of
code, I know what happens.
But in a more complicated
situation, it's very hard.
Even if you have the error
message and stack trace,
you won't be able to easily
identify where the issue is.
Maybe because you are
in a very big team,
or maybe because
you are developing
a very complicated
app, you don't
know every line of the code.
So as a software
developer, I really
wish I can do the debugging
in the real world productions
traffic.
But we know it's almost
close to impossible
because in your local instance,
you can debug with your ID.
You can [INAUDIBLE]
your application.
You can step
through all the code
and see what the environment
variable's value.
Or on other ways, it's
a more old school style,
is that you put [? log ?] lines.
And then you rebuild the app.
You run it.
And then you'll see
your [? bot ?] what's
happening in your application.
But we can not do it the
second way in production
as well because you don't want
to during your firefighting.
You'll at some [INAUDIBLE]
deploy your app to production.
And then up waiting for the
production traffic to hit it,
it will take hours.
And deploying a problematic
app during outages
make you even more riskier.
This is almost impossible.
But Stackdriver Debugger
make it happen for you.
So let's go to
Stackdriver Debugger.
So as you can see here, because
I deployed my code in GitHub,
that switched to my
GitHub repo with my code.
And if we scroll down, you
will see the same code there.
Within Debugger,
the thing I can do
is I can insert a logpoint
and a snapshot on my code.
And it doesn't affect any of
your production traffic at all.
But in the meantime,
it just assumes
this line is already in your
code and it exports a logpoint
or capture the snapshot
and then writing both
to Stackdriver logging.
And then you can see
what is happening, what's
the environment variable.
This gives you a
very close to real
debugging on your
real-world traffic.
Let's give a demo here.
So for example, in this line
54, that's the problematic line.
And let's add a logpoint, say,
OK, so I lost a coin toss.
So that's why I'm
about to throw a 500.
And then I log it as a error
log because it's easier for me
to [? field ?]
[? that ?] in future.
And let's save it.
Also, before I do the
final return, let's add--
in line 60, let's
add a snapshot.
That can give you a sense what,
before I'm returning this call,
what my service
environment looks like.
So we have already set it up.
We are waiting for
traffic to hit.
Because we already drained
the on-prem cluster,
now we have to manually
generate some traffic here.
So let's just go to
the owner details page.
We need to go to
owner details page.
And then let's
pick whatever one.
And this is the 500 that
customer's experiencing.
Let's refresh.
Refresh.
Keep refreshing.
Because it's tossing a coin so
sometimes it will get like--
apparently it's a
little bit unlucky.
You see a lot of 500 here.
So let's choose another one.
We see a success case.
Let's go back to debugging.
As you can see here, so this
is a call trace [INAUDIBLE]
success case has been
caught by my debugger.
Let's open on the variable.
This is on the
details [INAUDIBLE]
success case where
you can see this
is the name of this owner
which we see successfully
being returned and all
the environment variables
this JAR file contains.
We can also take a
look at a logpoint.
So for example,
this is like the log
has been returned into your
Stackdriver log storage.
This is where you can combine
with all your information logs.
You can understand what's
the flow, what's happening.
It gives you close to your
real-world debugging scenario.
And so this is the debugging.
Another tool we can show here
is also very useful, is trace.
Using trace, it can give you a
way to do the latency analysis.
Like for example, the
load we have generating
have all been captured
by Stackdriver tracing.
This is a distributed
tracing system.
And we can see how the
traffic flows [INAUDIBLE]
multiple back ends
in my services.
Let's pick a success case here.
As you can see, this is a
[INAUDIBLE] my on-prem cluster.
And at first, it goes
to the customer service.
We can open the logs here to
see what log has been written
by each of the services.
This log has been
written in the same time.
And you first go
to customer service
and then go to [INAUDIBLE]
service at the bottom,
as you can see here.
So this is the
collecting all the traces
from all your distributors,
this service call.
We call it [INAUDIBLE]
call as well.
And we can also take a
look at the 500 scenario.
If we switch here, and
it's filtered by 500,
there are some the error logs
we just [? hit. ?] So from here,
you can see if we
open the show logs,
this is where before
it hits any back ends,
it just throws a 500.
And this is the error
message and runtime
exception has been captured.
So could we switch back
to slides for one minute?
So this is the end of this demo.
JD VALASQUEZ: So as Shoucong
showed, the idea here, again,
is you have many tools
available from monitoring
to logging to debugger.
We didn't show you
error reporting today.
But there's a few errors
that you would see.
And we categorized those
errors directly for you.
So it's easy to do
exception analysis as well.
And when you use all
those tools together,
you get very rich,
comprehensive observability
of your Kubernetes environment.
Now, you can help with
multiple things, of course.
You can increase that
observability for making sure
that you get out-of-the-box
metrics that your Kubernetes
environment gives you.
And so we do that for you.
We take that toil away
from you to make it easy,
very much in the way that
Google does internally.
And you certainly can supplement
with third-party application
metrics and your
business-defined metrics
for which you can use
Prometheus or anything else
that you may want
for instrumentation,
hopefully using OpenCensus
so you can do it just once
and then choose any
other back end that you
may be interested in.
Make sure that these tools pay
attention to resource requests
and limits.
And so on some of it, the tools
that we have, on some place
it would show you
no data available
or no request or resource
request or limit set.
It is important, that's
a good best practice,
that you use that and set
your resource requests limits
in your Kubernetes environment.
And also, you want to make
sure that your information is
available in a consistent
way throughout.
So take advantage of
the Kubernetes labels.
That's the way in which
we organize information
all together.
So from your user-defined
labels to anything else,
so you can keep track of where
your application is no matter
where it's running in the many
different possible Kubernetes
components that may
be [? rescheduled. ?]
So we're now at the
end of the talk.
Thank you very much for joining.
We may have time for
a couple of questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]